the year was 2006 and the winter
olympics was happening in tour in italy
a lot of pressure was on the american
skater apollo ono for the 500 meter
finals and short track speed skating no
mistake about this and he said it i want
to win it was like something that i was
deeply
in pursuit of having a perfect strategic
race that would go my way
as he entered the final lap he
maintained a strong lead
you're almost like a little bit out of
control because you want it so badly but
you're also maintaining composure to
protect your lane and your position and
he pulled it off
after that gold medal apollo ono was
launched into mainstream fame
he was in ads he was on a wheaties box
his bandana and facial hair became
iconic he competed on dancing with the
stars and won
it was an awesome time but as an athlete
those
41.93 seconds meant something else too
and not because he was necessarily the
fastest skater going into the race but
the smartest and the luckiest
every single half a lap had to have
occurred in that way in order for me to
have had the perfect race and here's how
he did it
a short track race like apollo onos can
be broken down into four main parts the
first thing that went right was the
start
in short track four to six skaters all
start on the same line
and take off in a free-for-all short
track skaters don't have designated
lanes during the race unlike long track
skating or running events short track
skaters aren't racing the clock they are
only racing against each other
which is why short track is all about
the way athletes interact
jostling for the right position on the
rink trying not to fall and avoiding
disqualifications from a legal contact
[Music]
when skaters take off in the 500 meter
event they have one goal in mind
getting to the first turn first
research shows that whoever leads in the
first turn in the 500 meter event is far
more likely to win the race
the person in starting position one has
the shortest path to the first turn but
skaters in other positions with faster
starts could box position one in from
the outside
like the second position skater here at
the 2010 winter olympics
today short track skating positions are
merit-based that means the fastest
skater from earlier rounds gets the
first position
but at the time of the 2006 olympics
skater positions were computer selected
at random which would happen right
before the race
i'm in the locker room
i'm sharpening my skates i'm getting
ready
hear this like scream in the hallway and
it's one of our coaches who told apollo
that he was selected for the first
position
that stroke of luck and a fast start
helped apollo ono lead in that first
turn and hold it the whole way
a short track rink is an oval that
measures
111.12 meters this shape means that
skaters are turning nearly half the time
when they turn it looks like this it
actually looks like it doesn't make
sense at the apex of a corner skaters
are turning on an 8 meter radius
and can lean up to 22 degrees so close
to the ice that their left gloved hands
graze it
one short track skater told me that at a
speed of roughly 30 miles per hour they
are pushing against a g-force equivalent
to two to three times their body weight
like doing a really hard squat hunched
over at an angle on one leg
which is exactly how they train for
turns like these videos that british
short track skaters posted online show
in the 2006 race apollo ono used his
strength to keep his turns really tight
meaning i would hug the middle of the
apex of the corner all the way to the
seventh block so there actually was no
position to pass on the inside there are
two common ways of executing a pass both
require using the forces of the turn and
the right timing one is from the inside
the passing skater uses the draft of the
skater in front of them to pick up speed
then pulls wider on the turn
to slingshot out of the turn and
overtake the skater in front on the
inside like this pass from the 2014
sochi olympics
the other trickier pass is on the
outside the reason why it's so much more
difficult to pass on the outside is
because
you need to have significantly more
speed an outside pass starts at the apex
using the speed coming out of the turn
to sprint past the lead skater as you
enter the next turn
like this outside pass also at the 2014
sochi olympics
it's a confidence crusher if you pass
someone and they know that you pass them
easily you're signaling to them
oh by the way the four years of training
you just did it just wasn't enough
you're just not fast enough i'm sorry
when you're in the lead picking a track
pattern is how you keep from getting
past one common track pattern is the
diamond which defends against passes on
the outside
or the peanut pattern
which defends against inside passes
the first three laps apollo ono did a
mix of patterns to keep anyone in the
pack from picking up speed
so the idea was to kind of skate this
track pattern
that was a little bit confusing to them
where they would second guess
making a move it's like the person who's
walking in front of you in the mall who
like keeps stepping in front of you like
no matter how fast you go you have to
you have to like you have to you have to
restart your speed again on the last two
laps apollo ono kicked up the speed
and skated in a peanut pattern to
prevent an inside pass
i knew
that the likelihood of someone passing
me on the outside in the 500 meters at
the last two laps if i'm going 100 all
out was very low and so with two apps
remaining it's exactly what i did
the last element of short track is the
hardest to prepare for the best way to
illustrate this is another one of
apollo's races at the 2002 olympics in
salt lake city this one is infamous in
short track history
it was the 1000 meter final and apollo
was skating against underdog australian
skater stephen bradberry i was the
favorite to win that race nobody
considered steven to even be in the
running to medal as the skaters
approached the last lap apollo was in
the lead and steven bradberry was far
behind the pack
until a last minute scramble resulted in
this
four skaters go down
falls happen all the time in short track
racing because of the fight for the best
position on the rink and sometimes they
are beyond a skater's control
which means like other sports bad luck
can undermine the greatest skill
it also means resilience is a virtue in
short track you now have this like
unique ability to
either react and respond in a way that
will
give you a stewed bitterness for the
rest of your life
or you have to reset couldn't control
that i showed up as prepared as possible
life and the universe had a different
plan for me if you're apollo ono that
plan was that four years later he would
get his perfect race
no falls or blunders or passes just a
good clean win
[Music]
you